wait did Jennifer just call Siri ugly in
the third season of Netflix's The
Witcher what's that about the pet named
the Mage gives her young student may
sound harsh at first but there's a
deeper meaning at play however you feel
about the changes the second season of
The Witcher made to the initial
relationship between Jennifer and Siri
it's safe to say season 3 provides a
dynamic that more closely resembles that
of the Mage in her charge and author
Andre Z subkovsky's novels Blood of
Elves and the time of contempt not only
does the first episode see Anya
cholotra's Jennifer and Freya Allen Siri
grow into a more mother-daughter type of
relationship and begin to build a kind
of complex family Dynamic with Henry
cavill's geralt but the early episodes
of the Season specifically focus on
yennefer's evolving emotional capacity
and aptitude though the series gives
both characters a more tension filled
back and forth than in the books it also
draws heavily from subkovsky's depiction
right down to its use of book Jennifer's
nickname for her surrogate daughter
what would the consequence be then my
ugly one when Siri asks Jennifer why she
calls her that her answer is similarly
jablaced
why do you call me that because I
promised I'd be sincere with you from
here forward it's an Ever So slight
variation on her response in the books
from Blood of Elves she says I promise
to be sincere its intent in both the
book and the show is ironic and
affectionate but it's not exactly what
one would call a typical term of
endearment it's also a translation from
the original Polish language novels
which has for years prompted some fans
to question whether it accurately
portrays the original meaning in a
thread on The Witcher subreddit fans
discussed the possibility that the
English translation doesn't quite get
zubkovsky's point across in Polish the
word is brazidulka its straightforward
surface level translation is indeed ugly
specifically with regard to a young girl
but as one redditor points out in some
places in Eastern Europe it's something
not so unusual to take a word that on
its face has a negative meaning and turn
it into a cordial pet name so it becomes
a private joke between the two people so
the translation Gap isn't so much
linguistic as cultural while a few fans
were adamant that the translation itself
is simply bad most argue that the
subtext is clear regardless one wrote
even translated to English language and
other cultures one can read irony from
the get-go in the end using that pet
name in truth Jennifer's nickname for
Siri has little to do with looks and
everything to do with her assessment of
her charge's intelligence Jennifer knows
Siri is bright enough to understand
irony and self-assured enough or at
least has the capability to be not to
have to fish for compliments the
beautiful Mage also knows a thing or two
about how ultimately unfulfilling good
looks can be she's not about to let this
beautiful young girl get in the habit of
identifying too strongly with the power
those looks have over others
particularly not when she possesses such
real power what's more book Jennifer's
insistence that Siri avoid faking
ineptitude plays a significant role in
her simultaneously didactic and playful
use of the phrase there's also an
inherent affection in yennefer's use of
the words my and one the series which
more or less uses the exchange to nod
back to its source material doesn't
underscore this implication to the same
degree as the books but an analysis of
the novel reveals Jennifer's intent in
Blood of Elves it's clear Jennifer's
approach to her initially reluctant and
insecure pupil borders on reverse
psychology when Siri says she can't do
magic because her friends told older
virgins can't access magic Jennifer says
I can't see a solution so go out and
lose your virginity if it gets in your
way so much but be quick about it if you
please she's not about to entertain as a
more coddling instructor might the kind
of half feigned doubts and silly lines
of inquiry children so often engage in
to Garner sympathetic reassurance and
attention Siri also knows better than to
listen to such foolishness so Jennifer
treats her as though she's already grown
into that intelligence it equivalent of
a parent saying in a deadpan tone that
they have to go to the hospital when a
toddler falls down and instinctively
overreacts or cries despite not being
the least bit hurt Jennifer's nickname
for Siri comes from a similar place
though its function evolves as both the
pair's relationship and Siri grow her
instructive use of irony becomes an
inside joke American parents may not be
in the habit of calling their child my
ugly one but tongue-in-cheek is a
relatively universal language which
Jennifer helps Siri learn to speak
foreign